hey
it's magic
you know
what's your favorite sky rizzy song
oh the rizzo yeah uh
oh oh
i liked uh hey trees are big
hey mm-hmm
we're going
we're going yeah oh we're uh you're
listening to the dollop on the all
things comedy network this is a bi
sickle sickle american history podcast
where each week i dave anthony read a
story from the history of bicycles to my
friend gareth reynolds ding ding who has
no idea what the topic will be about oh
we're actually not doing ding dings
we had a meeting that's my calling card
i know but i'm the bell guy i know we
out the way ding ding that's how i
closed and opened shows throughout so
the whole team got together the whole
they're putting cheese and pizza crust
ding ding out of the way on that one
please coming through that's a great
example of what we don't want to do
anymore that's the stuff yes that's how
that's the bread and butter i don't know
if it is the bread and butter i think it
might just be the bread or maybe just
the crust of the bread that
that's what i'm talking about hey talk
about bread and butter this is just the
crust someone just gave me the heels
ding ding out of the way yeah see it's
not
it's not bad it's very bad i think
that's the i think that's the point who
are you on behalf of the whole team
everybody involved in the you know what
i sometimes feel like i needed a new
team ding ding out of the whale team
that's a great example
coming through yeah we're packaged on
the back
puppy in the front ding ding on the
bikes so i guess out of the way i guess
that's more accurate yeah thank god we
did this we've had a breakthrough in the
bike stuff so do you know go to the
intro song do you know larry boom boom
jenkins do the intro song he's going to
be coming in as the new co-host boom
boom yeah
i get the move uh do you yeah
uh the music
oh [ __ ] yeah that's what i was
now we got a vamp
[ __ ] this is um sometimes when dave
doesn't have it queued up i'm like ding
ding out of the way
who was doing this shitty idiot you
shitty it
shidiot yeah
hey [ __ ] it
here it goes
and called it quote his jam pack champ
i'm the [ __ ] hippo guy dave okay my
name's gary my name is is it for fun and
this is not gonna become a tickling
podcast okay
my friend
i guess i guess the question to ask is
how are aaron's ears and how are all the
listeners ears after so that is going to
play just as loud for the listeners
all right great
you're welcome listeners maybe but maybe
i won't okay sure um
are you doing ants what are we doing uh
you can do your little okay sure well
the first thing we got to talk about is
we have a great show coming up with
moment house we talked about we were
going to be doing it in november like
the 18th i believe uh due to unforeseen
circumstances we had to push the new
date is december
16th at 6 p.m pacific standard time we
will be doing a live virtual dollop with
moment house you can go to
momenthouse.com the dollop uh for
tickets to that
uh a great show so we're very excited so
that is a bit of a change but yeah we'll
be doing it december 16th 6 p.m pacific
standard time so i hit that dave that's
how you do it in the peas
i'm not going to be in bozeman anymore
that was last weekend what a time dave
uh also uh i will be in seattle
washington at laf's comedy club this
coming weekend friday november 19th and
saturday november 20th uh the following
weekend i'll be at the denver improv
that's friday december friday november
26 and the 27th i'll be at the denver
improv the next weekend the skyline
comedy club in appleton wisconsin dave
that's the first club that let me
headline the ding ding out of the way
not to them so go you can go to those
shows the next night sunday december 5th
i will be at the den theater in chicago
illinois next weekend i'll be in
indianapolis at the white rabbit
december 17th
and then i'll be in fort wayne on
saturday december 18th at
the tiger room
then i'll be in somerville massachusetts
sunday december 19th um i will be at the
crystal ballroom there and then i'll be
in kansas city for new year's very
excited going back to the comedy club of
kansas city there will be shows december
30th through january 1st bring in the
new year with your pal gareth not gary
uh and then we should also point out
dave that we will be at the san diego
observatory december 10th is that
correct
and uh you can go to dollop podcast
for tickets to all that stuff and you
can be in australia and we can go you
can go to garethreynolds.com for free in
australia in april yeah and we'll be in
australia in april i didn't know that
was ready to be said
okay
guys we're gonna be in australia tickets
have been on sale ring ring get out of
the way
what rick ring get out of the way
it's awesome we're brought to you in
part by
squarespace what is squarespace you ask
of course you're asking that because
you've never been outside look
it is domain website online store
marketing tool analytics it's got it all
we of course here at the dollop have
been uh we've had a very intimate
relationship with squarespace for a very
long time your uh committed committed
relationship committed my website as
close as it gets to marriage that's
right for me uh and then of course uh
our sources page and then the
dollarpodcast.com all squarespace we're
all in why because squarespace uh very
easy to use they got 24 7
award-winning support
uh you can buy your domains it's just
everything everything's in there the
templates look great that's why i first
started using squarespace because it
just looks very clean and nice they have
great templates you can go in
and try them out and mess around a
little bit see if that's what you'd like
and then you can and then you can sign
up for it so it's it's it's the way it
is
they have everything you want they got
the e-commerce the marketing tools all
the good the bells and whistles as they
call it
not not ring ring
so look uh here's what i'm saying go to
uh
squarespace.com
dollop for a free trial and then when
you're ready to launch you use the offer
code dollop to save 10
on your first purchase of a website or
domain
how about them apples pretty great
apples they are good apples
uh
stamps we are also brought to you in
part by
stamps.com have you heard of them gareth
yes i have i love stamps.com you do you
use it
yeah we both use it here look if you're
looking for ways to to
skip the trip to the post office
get away from all the crazy holiday
stuff that's going to be going on there
you're basically like bringing out the
way to all that nonsense yeah
and you save uh
so you save time and money if you use
stamps.com it lets uh
stamps.com lets you compare rates print
labels
access access exclusive discounts on ups
and usps services all year long
i've been using it it's very easy it is
very it saves you a lot of time yeah you
just you put it all together you print
it up on your
you get a scale from them you take care
of the package print up your label slap
it on there and then
and then the postman comes and picks it
up at your house so it's a that that's
what else could you want sometimes
they're on bikes it's got weird
uh
so uh look whether you're selling online
or running an office or
side hustle you've got a side hustle
stamps.com can save you so much time and
money and stress during the holidays
access all the post office and ups
shipping services you need without
taking the trip and yes oh interestingly
both those companies
are union
and get discounts you can't find
anywhere else like up to 40 off usps
rates and 76 off all
ups
i'm telling you gareth you got to get
involved save time and money this
holiday season
with stamp stock just get involved
save time and money this holiday season
with stamps.com sign up with promo code
dollop for a special offer that includes
a four-week trial free postage and a
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter code
dollop
boom
is larry here
[Music]
uh we are also brought to you in part by
ultimate ears
so ultimate ears is an earbud situation
uh it is absolutely fantastic
the
look it's just great technology it
sounds really really good it's when
you're when you get them and you're
going to make them fit for your it's
basically like you're living in
demolition man yeah it's future it's
future crazy that you download this app
and then they form to your ear they
lost one and it keeps them up it's gonna
form to your ear it's worth it even if
they weren't good it would be worth it
but they are great i thought i lost one
on the plane the other day
and it kind of ruined the flight yeah
because i was like at the end of the
flight i'll be able to find it won't i
i'll find it at the end of the flight
won't i and i did
yeah i mean they're they're really great
they sound really great i i bought a
pair for finn because he was like i want
those and they and i was like yeah you
should actually have these you're a man
now i'm a man now oh he is you've been a
man gotcha supposedly a while uh yeah so
like gary said they fit to your they fit
your ear which you don't have with
anything else any other earbuds i've
used because they always they're always
off a little bit but these ones boom
they're just in there they're great the
molding experience is awesome
they should just sell that yeah
seriously
[Laughter]
uh so
uh
sure you're about
oh yeah so airplanes are great i use
them when i'm working out now all the
time they're great for that yeah they
really are um
[Music]
okay so that we did that we did that we
did that
so look and if you try fits which is
what they're called we should say the
ultimate ear fits we should actually say
the name
if you try ultimate ear fits and don't
love them as much as we do no worries no
worries gareth ultimate ears offers a 30
day money back guarantee
plus you'll get free shipping free
returns and a one-year warranty for a
limited time get 15 off your pair of
ultimate ears fits wireless earbuds at
ue.com
fits
just use promo code dollop at checkout
that's 15 off with promo code dollop at
ue.com
fits
that's it
nice and we're out of here all right
good podcast that'd be so funny if one
time we just we should do that for april
fool's sponsors
and we'll just do sponsors and let's be
like secret episode
uh
i have a choice of two dollops right
here that we could do this is the first
this is your own dollar would you like
to do one about a lady or a fella
um
let's start with the lady
june 13
1873 year of our lord
jesus christ
i've been watching a lot of narcos
mexico oh good you're the kind of person
i think should be watching stuff
absolutely love that show absolutely of
course absolutely love it come on chapel
kill somebody all right let's remember
that we're doing a show yeah yeah yeah
but i'm on i'm totally we started the
other one i end up brooding for chapo
that's how that show goes there we go
but now it's done they're not making
anymore great
is it great no sarah i don't know i just
want to start our show
alice stebbins wells was born in
manhattan kansas sure
i'm in manhattan
oh wait [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah it's not great it's uh which
way is broadway mister
show i know never mind i'll just ask the
cabbie as soon as i hail one we here we
are sir we don't have it where's the
taxi we don't have any taxis well i'm
sure that a stranger will just pick me
up boy this city's known for whirlwinds
it's not look at it look at all the
which way is times
is it that there's a lot of corn we're
known for corn puffs where is the um
times square which way to broadway which
way to broad that's uh we have a main
street oh which way to me and then we
have first right i'll take the subway uh
which way is the cube where's the queue
enforcement where's the queue and
where's the queue where's the goddamn
train called cube and then nothing
where's the queue i want to head to
brooklyn we don't have trains what's
park slope like there's no park sloping
i think i'm in the wrong manhattan yes
this is kansas oh my
oh my god our our uh
slogan is hey we're not that good ah
yeah
anyway we named it the same and it's it
gets us a couple of tourists a year
like me yeah and you uh can't leave okay
well same diff yeah
i guess i just walk through this field
until i find a person start spending
money okay great thank you and watch out
i wouldn't go in the corner because of
malachi oh
the angel no oh
have you not seen children of the corn
no oh you've never seen children
now they're weird kids they come out of
corn come on come on right what else is
there
just a corn kid malachi wasted on you
just wasted i'm sorry
so alice's parents i'd make a lot of
references to the musical cats that you
don't understand
i've got my mystopolis drops
just keep reading the goddamn thing
uh aaron permission to treat my co-host
as hostile permission denied damn it yes
thank you aaron
uh so both of his parents had graduated
from oberlin college a rarity back then
right we were talking about the 1870s
they both moved to hiawatha kansas and
her dad started a town newspaper there
okay
the topeka daily called him quote rather
an odd character well hopefully his
paper is not the topeka daily it's not
okay
he's a real weirdo run with it i love it
headlines about me what a freak yeah
so alice went to high school in atchison
which is about 45 hours from 40 miles
away from hiawatha so she
either they moved there or she boarded
there or whatever in high school
no not a lot about her childhood that we
know so after graduating
like her parents she went to oberlin
college
and she became a pastor's assistant in
that's just like if you're gonna go to
college
gotta just be like an assistant to a
pastor a baby pastor it seems like you
could be an assistant to a pastor
without going to college yeah i think i
mean i i'm again i'm not trying to like
you know i'm sure there's some you're
[ __ ] on it
yeah yeah okay thank you
[Applause]
thank you thank you
if you're a pastor's assistant you just
need to read the one cloth
water bible
crucifix
i don't think either one of us know
anything about churches i just named a
bunch of things that are in churches
jesus
give me some jesus juice
give me the jesus juice the stuff we
drink give me his blood sweat his little
nose blood give me a cup of j blood oh
it's uh wine
that was a good year
give me a little body little body i'm
getting a little get a little crunked up
on that jesus juice give me a little
give me a little that body soak up that
blood stop
i normally eat a little body before i go
out on a night of blood pounding pastor
yeah i'm just telling you that you want
to line your stomach with some body
before you get into the blood pounding
right but you're scaring people this is
a sermon or something is that salmon
what is this
i'm in front of y'all bearing myself do
you
yes
i need more jewels on this cup if people
are gonna believe that christ's blood is
in it how did you get the job huh i went
to college
i'm the van wilder of
christianity i think that's what this is
i think it might not be whoops
i'm kind of worried about
let's do some blood funnels okay
now i'm in i'm gonna do a blood stand
so uh let's play blood pong
[Laughter]
um so
dr newell dwight
hills at plymouth church in brooklyn so
she moves to brooklyn and she's working
for that dude brooklyn kansas she's like
they've got a whole new york here
oh my lord
um and then she went to the hartford
theological seminary and she studied old
testament history and criminology
well
it's amazing to be like i'm going to
study religion and crime it's just
classic double major
[Laughter]
so
she would also fill in for pastors who
were on vacation in the northeast so
she's cruising around doing a little you
know sure
she was the first woman to hold church
services in maine okay
and she took a job as a pastor of a
perry oklahoma church in 1903.
i would imagine that there is great
resistance to a female pastor are you
kidding yeah
i mean burn it down it's a woman right
she lies only men talk to an invisible
man in the sky she can't tell me about
the lord she's got a vagina
impossible
so uh
while she was there she met and married
frank wells okay so her name is now alan
alice stevens wells okay
and frank's a farmer he'd come from
wisconsin
yeah
go
packer they had three kids okay
as a pastor alice came to believe women
should be cops
okay interesting because she would see
uh
she would see how cops interacted with
women
and thought it wasn't working if you can
imagine so she feels like they're like
some sort of club
club yeah like they're just like a crew
of people who don't let outsiders in and
then they just have their own like
secret coded language and really are
just like a vigilante squad towards
people who are not them
get out of here
alice so
she thought that women could be more
effective than men in certain situations
like if women cops went into the problem
is you have to pitch this to men yeah
that is the problem yeah but uh what
you're missing is that you have the mind
of a woman
and that is affecting and clouding your
judgment that is wrong
so if cops
went into dance halls or skating rinks
or picture houses
with children and women
more difficult for them to relate to
than a woman is what she said for sure
um so the wells family ends up moving to
los angeles i couldn't figure out what
for but he had a business opportunity
and alice got there and she started
campaigning for women to be on the
police force okay
and uh across the u.s
at this point female suspects were being
beaten
or worse by cops if you could imagine
like that was happening back then i mean
we've gotten rid of that yes it's hard
to imagine a force yeah it really is i
mean the world we live in now is
obviously different yes
yes because we said so
uh a sex worker had been badly beaten
during an arrest at an la barber shop
that was also a boarding house jesus
sounds like a lot was going on at that i
mean it's like four different things i
just
i i'm just in my mind the idea that a
barber shop is also a boarding house
pretty great it's really the most
upsetting thing pretty great it's
they just sleep on the floor yeah they
had to well yeah at the end of the day
you have little hair beds
you don't sweep by the end of the day if
you don't sweep you've got what i would
call a cushy floor come on get in there
hamsters time to go to bed here we go
there's some long curls over here if
anyone likes a real soft blade
[Laughter]
so yeah so uh so that was a big deal and
alice thought female cops would lead to
less violence against women
sure of course this is what again this
is back when
everybody agreed they didn't like cops
before um
dragnet well yeah basically before
dragnet before tv and movies told us
that cops are good nobody like cops dude
i i've i guess i've just been keying
into it recently but it
i when you actually do really look at
how many shows are about
cops or emergency workers or hospitals
it's like
the
i mean there's just so many shows that
are like cops are perfect they're
figuring out stuff they're a team yeah
like i mean still law and orders like
how long is that nothing
ever
ncis is like ncis cincinnati we don't
know there's nowhere else we don't know
what else
ncis prim and they solve uh i think it's
two percent of crimes is how many they
actually solve so law and order is
already it'd be so good if there's a law
order at the end of every one they're
like i don't know man oh another murder
happened we were wrong [ __ ] all right
what is this show
it's just called it's not even it's just
called and
this week on didn't get them
uh so right so people don't like cops
and a lot of california cities had
already
they had
women matrons since the 1890s
what does that mean so they specialized
in the care of female prisoners
and they worked in the city in county
prisons so they already knew like let's
not have dudes around right women who
were locked up because that can be a bad
situation
so alice starts talking to anyone who
will listen in la and she's going she's
not going to the
police she's going to like pastors and
people who have a lot of influence in
the city
and uh everyone's getting on board
they're like yeah that sounds great so
when her proposal gets to the los
angeles city council
pretty much the whole community supports
it
okay and uh
she basically wills the city through
activism to allow female cops okay wow
and the city council enacted uh the law
and it went into effect in 1910. okay so
on june 8 1910 alice had a meeting with
los angeles mayor
george alexander who's scottish
he's not gonna be around long i'm sorry
but he is scottish well i'm in charge
for a little while what do you want to
ask me
she asked where you should go she asked
why do you ask me a question
she has to be a cop you'd like to be a
police officer yourself yes you think
you'd fit
in the blue with the badge yeah and the
gun yeah and the button yeah you think
you can have a baton yeah you think your
bit's on quality yeah yeah i'll tell you
what you're but off
you're right off honestly i think the
problem is you've not been in church in
a while so you're looking for you've got
idle hands which they say is the devil's
playground you go go in there give a bit
of a sermon right that seemed to be your
call and get your crucifix on you know
have your crucifix your cruiser fix like
you need it
all right let me walk you through a
situation since i'm not gonna be around
long right there's a hostage situation
in a barn right two equines inside of it
okay you you only got four bullets
there's two chips what you got question
what's an equine it's a horse you fall
christ almighty
okay okay so a horn you've got horses
you've got two children hostage
situation nurses are holding the
children no bloody bloke is holding the
blood they do they already horses are
irrelevant there's two children there's
a man he's got two children inside of a
barn
is he behind the horses he's i said you
don't know the situation that's the
whole thing you've not got extra bloody
vision we've not even got bloody x-ray
what are you doing
what do you do well i set the barn on
fire welcome aboard
you are the one
so uh
she talks to him she asked me made a cop
uh sorry this is the mayor right so the
mayor looks at her uh she's 36 okay
she's five to 120 pounds okay if you're
from another country 1.5 meters mm-hmm
um
the mayor quote how
can you be a police officer
how could you be a police officer it was
like that yeah yeah
she said she wasn't planning on using
physical force and that she didn't
actually want to make arrests quote
i want to keep people from needing to be
arrested
there's not a job for you we've not got
a position for that
you want to prevent the cops from doing
their job while being a cop
she's just like yeah i want everyone to
be okay you want people to be
it sounds like you're want to protect
and to some extent serve
yeah that's right well it's not it's
bloody laughable yeah i'm sorry but
that's is absolutely foolish yeah
so alex you should kill him
the point is to kill them the whole
reason i want to do this so that doesn't
happen that's why we need more females
fundamental issue and understanding what
it means to be an officer of the law
yeah okay you kill them then you arrest
them no then we put them on trial after
they're dead
that's why we do that yes i will bless
it
so alice told the mayor that more and
more young men and women were going to
be
uh were going to undesirable cafes and
other places of amusement so she's like
look
young ladies and a little innocent young
men and ladies are going to bad places
right
a woman could often stop that sort of
thing where a man would only arouse
antagonism a woman knows better how to
deal with situation where a girl's
welfare is concerned yeah the idea that
there's
i'm not really understanding how like
it's so
yeah yeah no [ __ ] uh yeah you'll
probably relate to the women more that's
right yeah that makes sense
alice told the mayor oh sorry the mayor
then said no ordinance permitted a woman
to be a cop
and alice uh whips out the document
she's like right here 35 of la's leading
citizens have signed it from bankers to
preachers they had signed a petition
demanding women
be made police officers and the and the
council city councils voted on it and
los angeles is exploding at this time
the population had tripled between 1900
and 1909 okay
and it's now a city of 300 000. there's
uh it's still got an old western vibe
sort of right uh and there's gambling
and prostitutional and stuff
cultures morals clashing you know and um
with all those signatures from city
leaders mayor alexander comes around to
the idea of a lady cop he's like all
right well everybody wants it okay
except for me right that by the way
though that is uh
nice to hear that public demand is like
you eventually go like okay well i mean
maybe if everybody wants it let's try if
you [ __ ] idiots want this let's go
for it we'll try oh you got a dumbass
petition uh yeah that's fine well it
seems like you're okay you can be an
officer
so you're so tiny though
[Applause]
do you know how little you actually are
you're so small
aaron just walked out
now we can now we can do the show
oh [ __ ] nothing
no is it mail
no
well the power cord
so uh
so later that day he the mayor told a la
times reporter quote many young girls
and boys are started on evil lives and a
woman could easily discover these things
where a uniform policeman could not okay
so she rationality she can find the evil
right she's the evil finder well she's i
mean i get yeah yeah of course
now my question is were there dog cops
before lady cops
oh i i don't know when dog cops came in
it would be interesting to see if they i
bet there were
males were like dogs make sense women
are crazy
i mean because they use dogs to do crowd
control for years so it would make sense
that they already had but yeah maybe we
should look into that before bloodhounds
like you know there's that one smell
that rag there now see if you find him
on the rag nash is he yeah
um so the police commission then meets a
few days later to consider it
and uh chief alex chief galloway is
worried uh
so the police chief is alexander
galloway i think he's also a scottish
we'll find out well you know he is i
just got actually just found out he is
um he's worried alice would take orders
from women's clubs
churches and charitable organizations
who had signed the petition so his
concern is that
i mean
it's it's amazing who the bad guys are
well unfortunately she might be
influenced by these good natures
organizations could be terrible
can women take uh do they take orders
from uh men or how does it work yeah
we're not sure do they hear what men say
stuff do they what is that
in my house
you know the wife all right
look we're testing to see if the female
mind is capable of absorbing rules and
regulations i'm like hey don't go buying
a new dress today and she comes home
with a new dress again can't afford that
extremely specific to your household
which is not exactly what we're after
now
i'm a different now scotsman i'm the
police chief
to be clear
when i ask for sexual favors stop
take five minutes outside of the room
please
prospectus stop
talking for a minute please
this is
a meeting about something that is not
pertaining to your household exclusively
this is good stop to get your mouse open
and that's a problem right away should
not be preparing to have speech
i think outside the room would be the
best place for you for a little bit just
to you know recognize where you are and
are there women or women no it's not
about going to find women or have any
sort of sexuality it's not about sex and
just
well why would you want what don't i
don't
they're just around
you look climb out the window and stand
on the ledge for a moment okay you if
it's nice and you know cold out there
and you'll be alone i think that's right
never think have a long think
are they gonna be women down on the
ground that i can see i look we're about
five stories up so i don't think the
idea of don't even think about women
here's the deal
i like them right
crazy
it's like our brains are different like
like they're from mars to the bottom and
i'm from venus well that's
you understand it's a crazy way of
putting it that makes no sense
get out the window
you know what i need
a little bit of chicken and soup for the
soul what the hell's going on
he was a future book predictor
so um
so uh he's worried about that it's
obviously [ __ ] he thought
their uh those women were there to push
women's interests and that's why they
were getting her on the force it's also
amazing at a time when like women are so
yeah they happily represented that he's
like careful
they might try to be
like us well they want to vote they
might want fairness
uh the chief wanted a promise he wanted
a promise that alice would report to him
and follow department rules instead of
doing some lady cop being a rogue rogue
lady cop yeah right the commission
assured him she'd be working under him
and they approved her okay
so then they discussed her salary oh god
thinking we could give you one brush a
month
patrolman made 102 a month okay so the
chief said she should get 75. okay right
i mean
it's amazing that we've always been like
you're three-quarters of us do you
understand you're a three-quarter
version
and everyone agreed that made sense that
makes
obviously
alice was then sworn as the in as the
first female cop in los angeles on
september 13 1910 some people say she
was the first cop but she wasn't there
were a couple others around the first
female cop yeah okay she wasn't okay um
she
she wasn't to be called a policewoman
but instead a woman policeman
why
who gives a [ __ ] why because they in
their brains are like well that's a
policeman
a policeman's a policeman so we can't
call it a police woman because they're
all policemen so
i don't know what we're gonna do we're
gonna think of a problem we're
reconsidering putting you on the force
as is we're not we have not been able to
figure out the title that makes sense
what about and hear me out woman
policeman
too close
really good because it describes the
whole thing not man cop because she's
being a she's being a cop but she's not
a man cop
which isn't a thing lady enforcer not a
police yes
that's a pitch of a name yeah less money
less cop three-quarter cop yeah not man
yeah hyphenated i think that works it's
great that's really good
can't get it out of my head i could say
it again if you asked me to uh she also
would not be
allowed to carry a gun like male cops
it feels a little um which performative
it sounds like she was fine with based
on what she wants to do
so she i mean
she's doing what is
difficult but smart which is
sort of like yeah uh agree to these like
make these concessions
because she still wants to do the things
she wants to do she's not getting caught
up in like the egoed nature of how
you know [ __ ] up that really is she's
going okay yeah right i'm a non-man cop
and i don't get guns
great but i don't think she doesn't want
a gun because she's right her whole
thing is like demanding escalations are
violent and we don't want that so she
doesn't want the gun
what the hell
press asked if she would carry a billy
club and she said she would just rely on
being a woman we're going to call that a
sally club
quote the weapon nature gave a woman was
a scream and in civilized communities it
is invincible
okay okay yeah so she's got she's
interesting answers yep
so she's gonna she's gonna scream okay
like a woman she's like a woman scream
she has a particular woman scream that
nature that's how the siren gets
invented that's exactly how it gets
invented
although she acknowledged in rural areas
a scream might not cut it okay so
quote
it would not be bad to know a few
bone-breaking tricks okay so in rural
areas she's getting trained for
well she uh she was actually studying
jiu jitsu and kept a hat pin on her head
there we go which she called quote the
best weapon and most to be depended on
wow jujitsu and a hat pin that's a
[ __ ] up this is like an origin story
yeah it's a scary person there yeah yeah
coming at you with that throws you down
hat pin out of the stole reporters quote
i will deal chiefly with the proprietors
of such places and we'll see that all
laws are obeyed and the places are kept
clean and moral
okay moral moral police
yeah i mean essentially yeah
and more quote this is
serious work and i do hope the
newspapers will try not to make fun of
it oh boy or as the times wrote quote
said the little woman yesterday as she
left the police station
and by the way
they're probably not they're probably
they're like that was a nice way of
putting it yeah she's a little tiny
woman she's a little tiny woman and she
left the the doll lady left
finally a cop you can throw doll woman
leaves
baby cop actually woman
just the fact that they printed her
quote yeah and then and then said that's
what the little said the insignificant
little non-man
so this is national news the whole new
honolulu advertiser got down to the
important stuff quote she will not have
to don a uniform
nor is it supposed that she will favor a
hobble skirt what's a hobble so hobble
skirts were skirts that were designed so
you
couldn't like run or walk very well
they're they're
they're like only they're shaped like um
almost like a reverse pair
so it's up here and then it goes down so
your your legs
i just you know if there's a if if
there's an item of clothing and part of
the description is hobble don't they
shouldn't be
they shouldn't be around it's called the
stumble gown
other papers uh got down to the
important stuff the la times wrote her
police badge quote pinned over her heart
hid as much of her little self as a
breastplate would
again they're just saying she's saying
like the badge takes up her chest l.a
times cannot stop saying she's tiny the
tiny woman put the badge on her back and
walked away like an aunt who'd found
bread
cartoonists nationwide
drew her but they drew her as a big bony
muscular woman because they couldn't
imagine a small woman being a cop what
they seem to be unable to do is just
like be like she's a woman
they're like she's so small no she's a
big ogre lady
no she's like a person
how could she do her job well she's not
going to beat people up she's a big
knuckle dragon weird woman she looks
like she lives in the sky
she's a troll
the the cleveland plane dealer wrote
that she quote should be properly
chaperoned
we need a cop
we need to put a cop on it we need a can
we absolutely need a cop absolutely
she's just gonna walk around on her own
that's crazy what if someone attacks her
exactly we should scream yeah we should
have a cop who would never attack anyone
yep exactly he won't hurt her yep
safety enforcers yeah yep
she'll feel better like that oh yeah
just going to oliver calls all right
let's go i'll get my gun out no no no no
no no what we're going to shoot these
people they're shouting at each other no
we should kill them no we will beat them
with our guns no we're gonna we would
drive them in water we will hurt and
beat them kill them we're gonna defuse
the situation we will use a bomb exactly
and we will light the fuse no then the
defuse goes off and we blow them all up
and then i'll shoot into the smoke we're
gonna de-escalate the tension and make
it so people don't we'll go in there and
i will shoot everyone with my gun and
i'll kill you if you keep talking to me
right is that what am i what is
happening calm calm down let's settle
down is what i'm saying settle down
you're getting a little ladyish no
you're you're being a lady about it
chill out why are you shaking me i'm not
shaking anything i want to talk to you
about the plan now what i think we
should do is simply burn them
burn all of them and then we can walk no
we don't want to go get tacos we want
everyone to go let's get
i want to go away yeah exactly that's
right yes
hurting each other
they won't be able to hurt each other no
one's getting hurt they won't hurt each
other you they will be gone you we will
eviscerate them with fire you we will
ask them hurting people me not hurting
right the gun hurting no me holding the
gun hurting no me hurting the gun with
the hand
shoot yeah shoot them yes okay no for a
minute it sounded like you were pushing
back so i'm like maybe you're not fit
for this we'll go in there no and i will
just this is what i'll do i'll run in
there and i'll just shoot everybody
right then we'll burn it let's not do
that any of that okay i'll go in
you're gonna get burned and shot if you
go in i'm gonna talk to them what about
that they're gonna be killed i don't
think they should have that heads up i
really alice and then they're all gonna
die we're gonna talk them out of the
violence and then everyone will go home
oh wait a second
that's great
we'll murder them in their homes
that is so much harder to know that we
did it this whole time when i'm talking
to you i'm like does she have rocks in
her head no
you are thinking i do understand your
purpose now okay we'll wait to murder
them i was impatient yeah
so i'm just gonna go ahead and give up
well
that's not gonna necessarily say that
you don't get hurt
okay so
the sams the san francisco chronicles
headline was quote skirts among police
this may come next
so everyone's handed skirts
okay so everyone's handling it very well
yep everyone's rational
the in richmond the times dispatch
reported their police chief said quote
when i was a youngster the women used to
stay at home and mine the babies and
there was always quite a big crop of
babies in those days
miss alice stebbins wells will soon get
tired of twaddling with that stick of
hers and she'll run into a proposition
in one of these nights that will take
all the curl out of her marshall waves
so he hit him like he's ready to do this
i mean
i love the i love the argument that
things used to be different is like in
any way viable to anything
especially in this country well you know
what we used to do it's like yeah no we
do and we're adjusting yeah we know what
we used to do right we're trying not to
do that we used to own my when i was a
boy we owned people
it's a lot harder now
you should go back to that way for me
on her first day she went to galloway's
office to get her badge
now
his walls were covered in pinup girl
posters he's the chief
he's scottish
and he's an ex-railroad superintendent
with zero police experience
that's why he just got the job well you
don't need training when you're not
trained am i i'm scottish
as he put the badge on alice he told her
quote sorry to offer a woman so plain an
insignia of office
so i think he's saying it's just a star
it's not like a flashy oh right he's
like bro yeah right exactly right yeah
it's not as complex as your brushes that
you would often wear i'm assuming no
diamonds this is a batch
this is not uh
this is not meant to tie the outfit
together do you understand yeah okay
okay thanks i know what about and we
don't have a crown or receptor okay yeah
i don't want anything without that lady
stuff
here's your tiara yeah here we are
officer tiara is here
uh and then uh after that he
said once he had quote a squad of
amazons he would ask the police
commission to design a star edged with
lace ruffles wait once he had so he said
once he had a squad of really big
amazonian women
then he would ask the commission to
design a star with dave i know i like
that there's a time where that shorthand
was so
like people i know what he means
of course
finally he topped it all quote you
wanted this job and apparently you know
what you want to do well go ahead and do
it
so he's he's not he's hands off he's
he's not a great
he's not in he's not on board with the
idea if you don't mind leave me alone
i'm going to be in my office
masturbating for the remainder of the
afternoon
she was given a telephone box key right
so the call key they used to
so if you if people don't know there
used to be boxes all over the place and
you would go over open it up if you're a
cop i like that you think i knew any of
this and you would call into whatever
that's how so it's yeah there were no
walkies you'd just get your cops and
you'd hello it's me i'm an officer
downtown it's frank i'm over on third
and third hurry
um
so she also got a book of rules and a
first aid book
no plans to give her a uniform
okay
other cops didn't know what to do around
her
she approached her sergeant and he was
in shirt sleeves which is bad form
around a woman at that time you're not
supposed to be in shirt sleeves oh my
god oh oh my lord he leapt up put on a
coat saying quote either you'll have to
get used to this or or we will
yep that's kind of the idea sort of
pretty much yep that's where we're at
yeah i don't know how this is going to
work
i guess we're going to have to change
but he said yeah he's saying that in a
way of like i mean something's gonna
have to change and that just seems crazy
you know when i was a boy you weren't
allowed to talk to me yeah you were not
looking the eyes not talking the whole
thing you're making babies in the in the
house okay well yeah so
i guess we'll sit around here with the
jacket on okay not a big thing i really
while you were here
yeah is there do you always sound like
that no i just uh it's very uh oh i'm
gonna put a jacket on at the office it's
just very weird yeah well i just think i
guess because you're here right but you
normally would just have on a shirt i
should my arms would be bare just out
okay well either way or sort of like
whatever it's not either way it's one
way i mean you're a woman you can't see
my arms if you see my arms you're gonna
want to make babies
oh i mean i saw your arms uh so so i'm
good are we no
no no no doing this no no no absolutely
not no
no i'll be okay
i saw your arms and i'll be like
i'll be around you come on i don't like
you hearing you say it saying that i saw
you
okay
well i won't tell anyone that i saw him
and just so you know even if i did see
them it it's not that sort of your brain
no burned in there it isn't it'd be like
if i saw you naked
i don't like that we're going there and
i'm doing that in my head please don't
tell me you're doing that and please
don't do that i do it to uh jeff also
well that's great good to everybody i
have a week okay well then i guess you
should do it i might not maybe i
shouldn't be a cop now that i think
about it i i mean i don't know you well
so i don't want to weigh in on that but
i i guess it's because when i was giving
a speech as a kid my father was like
picture him all naked so you don't get
nervous i just do it all the time okay
great that's great and that's great to
know and you know that i don't do that
sort of stuff but for if that's what you
need to do that's great and i saw and i
think you look good in the jacket so i
don't think we need to worry about
anything we're okay here thinking about
my arms huh
i'm thinking about my arms right now
okay well that's still you saw them and
you're under the jacket they're naked
yeah okay i i have to
um not be here there's somewhere else i
have to be thank you so thank you thank
you you finally got to the part where
you're not here i i'm is as much as this
isn't a great situation i do feel like
some progress was made so i feel like i
feel like screaming okay well i guess i
have a different read on the moment than
you do but um okay well anyway welcome
to the force thank you really great to
hear someone say that because it's been
a while and nobody's even
she didn't sigh for so long just now but
there it is okay all right take care
oh my god his arms
be still
uh
there was no office for her
so the bailiffs set her up in a spare
courtroom
she would have to leave if a judge
needed it
excuse me i'm going to have a child now
that's the point pardon
it was full of shelves with files and
had rats running around so that's where
they put her oh you want to go in the
rat store why did you go to rat court
you ever been to raccord a lot of cheese
trials i think ladies like ratcourt
there you are
people just didn't know how to handle
her once she jumped on a street car
so they cops could ride street cars for
free right uh so she jumped on a screen
car and showed her police star which was
number 105
um to get the usual free ride and the
conductor got furious because he didn't
believe she was a cop and he yelled at
her for taking her husband's back yeah
yeah i know that ain't yours there's no
way
that's cool wow not only could it not be
a woman cop i also don't read the papers
how yeah that's what i was just gonna
say everybody would know how do you not
know well it's just like the people now
who you talk to them when they're like
what
i would climate change by the way
be honest
do you envy them in some way oh a
hundred percent i was talking to someone
over the weekend who doesn't was telling
me how they don't really think about it
i was like
god i just oh just the end yeah
envy sounds great totally envy it's
really looking bad
yes whatever really
yes scientists are going crazy it snowed
in minneapolis
uh
so he makes her get off the street car
and after that she went and got a new
star with policewoman engraved on it and
number one you took your wife's badge
get off of here
on august 4 she was outside a theater on
main street when a 45 year old man
thomas gibbons winked at her okay
she walked over and asked him if he
winked at her
and he said he'd like to buy her a drink
and winked again oh my god double wink
the drink wink wink she said okay and
then led him several blocks to the place
they were gonna have a drink which
turned out to be the central police
station
this place serves booze and she told the
sergeant to book him
no bail uh for disturbing the piece wow
so she's a [ __ ] cop right so now so
now she's a cop but doesn't she have to
like lay doesn't she have to put a beat
down on in some way
like doesn't she have to do something
i mean it's not it's
wrong it's not illegal women aren't
waking up men and it's not but it's also
like she's like i want some respect and
i'm not getting it so i'll make an
example of this but this is the cop
mentality it is you don't get to arrest
that guy
he did he did a bad thing i also i like
leading him to the drink so he's like
well i'll get there i'm gonna have a gin
martini she's like yeah what are you
gonna have bib
i don't know maybe just uh who knows
some midori or something oh it's great
so they have little snacks on the bar we
can have some chex picks
so the guy is a father he's married
and then he admitted he winked but he
said he had a nervous condition that
made his eyelashes i have wrinkle titus
i should say you know he is booked and
they they do it all so this is in court
right and he's in rack court he tells
him he has a nervous condition that made
his eyelashes twitch i have i have i
have twitch lash
medic my doctor told me it i have uh i
have what's known as worst worst excuse
itis uh a lot of guys
not guilty not guilty a lot of men have
that i have that
the judge ruled alice asking if he
winked was ambiguous and let him go
i i feel him
he's not right i mean i'm just trying to
find her the guy the guy clearly winked
yeah but but the uh
it's the judges i think the judge is
saying like what do you [ __ ] do i
mean what are you [ __ ] doing yeah the
judge is just like we will wink at you
uh so the arrest brings her tons of
attention nationwide the endlessly
stopped winking it oh yeah i'm sure with
that guy the atlanta constitution quote
when you wink at women you use a lot of
caution
so that's
that's their wink from a distance uh you
want to be on a wing kill hey jimmy i'm
going to show you guys how to cautiously
wink okay we're going to do what's
called a drive-by winking
we're going to drive by wink nice and
cautious that's right right so that one
i don't even know what you're doing you
know what i like to do yeah this is a
great one i do the blink oh yeah so both
eyes both eyes but if i like her i turn
my head a little so she can't see the
blink so i'll go like
that looks like a wig to you right no it
looks like you have a good condition
great i have a condition legally i'm
clear yeah yeah yeah
oh you ever do that do you ever do
there's something in my eye that's
another good one the wink and then if
they look pissed you go oh my god
there's a bug in there you ever uh you
ever wink and lick your lips at the same
time oh the winky lick you got to be
careful i wouldn't do that anymore
actually i've seen you do it i probably
would never do it not very good no it's
a lot of that's hard it's hard to see
looks like i see an enemy coming out of
a dead man
okay that was for you
great
uh so
yeah so it's it's nationwide like people
are like this is crazy a woman arrested
a guy from william the oregon daily
journal quote mr gibbons winks at
woman policemen but by the way this
dude's like look all right i'm really
really i don't i'm really sorry i do
have a wife and i do yeah like she's
really pissed can we keep it down uh dr
wink mr wink will you come out and talk
to us
but
after this the department began a
campaign against public flirts okay see
that's what i mean a little bit it's
like
it does speak to an issue it is an issue
i guess but it's not something you
prosecute okay
i'm not i'm not like
i don't disagree but it's like the hat
pin was handling it all
well yes i bring them back i'm in yeah
uh
the uh they so they hired an attractive
woman named faye evans to walk the
streets
and three plainclothes cops would follow
her
and uh arrest men who flirted with her
and they quickly arrested nine men i
mean oh my god for flirting
hey baby that's it jimmy and what'd i do
yeah i flirted with that lady there you
see a attractive lady you can't flare
with her by the way the cops when
they're like and if any of the guys flew
with you which again like how could they
not you're so pretty yeah yeah but if
any of them are kind of giving you the
creep vibe you know give me a hand let
me hold it
you know
if any of them is okay just rub your
hands
we're gonna
charlie's gonna rub your hair and i'm
gonna rub your hammer we'll talk you
through what's gonna happen okay
uh yeah so they arrest nine guys people
are not happy about what are you in for
i said hello to a woman the
wife of one of the arrested men found
evans and started beating her up with an
umbrella wow wow
like a cartoon how dare you uh the
department then fired evans and uh
killed operation bad flirting okay
because people were just like this is
crazy yeah
i mean men putting men in the the
headspace publicly of
can i say hello to her is just at this
time is phenomenal
in november can i please have change
not in my hand put it on the counter
don't look at me in the eyes i know i'm
irresistible
in november lily maud allen disappeared
in london okay
some people thought she had been
kidnapped by a cult okay three months
later lily popped up at ellis island
where she was detained by immigration
but she managed to get away
okay once again she disappeared some
dock workers said they had seen her
being escorted off by surly people in
blue uniforms
and they had silver lettering on their
caps with the words pillar of fire
what do you want from me what the [ __ ]
is going on what pillar of fire hats
i introduced you to columbo and now i've
started the episode
yeah right credits
uh on february 4th 1911 now police chief
so the police chief that we had before
galloway the scottish guy he's out
it's difficult to retire because he had
no experience unfortunately i don't know
what i'm doing in any way i got this job
because i wanted an office where i could
put attractive women on have a work in
the office on my own
i've had a great run of 12 years and
sitting in my dirty prairie office
blinds closed
but recently i understood that a woman
was on the police force and i just made
it seem so strange to spend my
afternoons in there having wanks
when she's there
so it's with a heavy heart that i must
leave this job that's meant so much to
me again i'm not really sure if i've
done much but
god almighty was i wanking in that
office i i think you were our best
police chief ever a lot of those pin-up
girls weren't even pinned to the wall
they just stick because of their level
of wanking no hold on let me finish
get the bloody hand off me yeah i'm
finishing
the amount the most amount of times i
had to work in there for anyone curious
was a dark day
i had 15 wanks that day
okay lost a lot of good men yeah
potentially this is alex
absolutely so we'll open up the
questions soon no they will all be about
wanking
anyone got question about wanking
all right i'll open it up to other
questions that are about the pinups
does anyone have a question about how i
would wank
why i would wank
my favorite one to wank too well i've
got that one right here if you'd like to
look
thank you for the watch
great
why is everyone so bloody quiet
[Laughter]
uh so the new police chief charles
sebastian gets a message from the denver
police chief and he says lily allen
is traveling under an alias ruth allen
and crafty
and the pillar of fire had been founded
there in denver 10 years before
and so there were connections and the
chief said he thought lilly had gone to
los angeles
what is the pillar of fire they're just
we're going to get there okay
uh so the pillar of fire been in l.a for
a while a pillow of fire was first
called when it was established in denver
the burning bush movement
and it was started by a woman named alma
birdwell
white she's 48 she's tall
heavy had gray hair
and she was in denver and some methodist
ministers scolded her and told her women
belonged in the home so she decided to
start her own church okay
and it catches on
and her followers were called holy
jumpers and they stomped and they
convulsed and they do this while
standing on street corners and uniforms
just normal religious stuff i'm waiting
for something strange one paper said
they were quote opposed to dancing
drinking smoking theater going divorce
card playing novel reading pretty close
christmas trees taxi cabs joy rides
hobble skirts peach basket hats poodle
dogs massage parlors no poodle forest
ladies straight
front corsets artificial teeth make
believe hips and busts
and highly seasoned
make-believe that's not fake
make-believe i'm imagining i have hips
i'm a hippie lady
and highly seasoned mince pies oh my god
that's a little too much seasoning god
will not like that so they are religious
yeah they're religious and they
basically believe in just laying down
and drinking water yeah they have a list
of stuff you can't do and it's
everything okay
sounds great
all these things are considered but
kidnapping is cool yes
all these things are considered the
devil's work to them so the burning bush
moves to l.a in 1904
and white said they're just a christian
revival group they just wanted to
reintroduce method methodism to uh
people okay
and um they're very loud
sure they set up at uh 315 south olive
street and from the building people
heard shouting and shrieking and moaning
and wailing in l.a yeah wow
and uh a loud drum would bang the whole
time so people living nearby are like
this is fun must have an audition
because it's going on 24 7. right
this has to stop oh my god
so the cops come but then no one wants
to file a complaint
okay so the cops can't do anything
and then why is that they're just
fearful scared of them right okay
soon they moved into a revival tent
outside of the banking district or where
the noise continued but then hundreds of
locals are like well what is this it's
interesting i'm gonna start coming to
check it out
and i'd see people shaking and crying
and banging their hands pretty cool on
benches
until um they were red
because god was possessing them hit the
bench god wants people to bang on
everyone hit that bench now and scream
and fall down and fake a seizure my god
wanted good
jesus came out
from the tomb and said let's hit benches
everyone falls sizzle like bacon that's
the religion
uh the la times wrote that white was
using some sort of mass hypnosis sure
and rumors start
about people burning their most prized
possessions in bonfires and human
sacrifices okay taking another stranger
let's put all of our favorite things in
there and then we'll burn joan
okay and then we'll light all our
favorite stuff on fire and joan will go
in it okay this is god's plan i like it
i'm joan and i want to be in the fire
here we go gonna miss these books bye
joan
at some point white i don't know what i
don't know how because this is her thing
but she splits off from burning bush and
starts a separate one
okay pillar of fire okay which she's in
complete control of so i guess she
started i think the first one she had
like a group that helped run it right
now she's like no i gotta i gotta be the
one right
so quote my word is final
yes
she also said quote oh people are like
horses no good until their spirit is
broken
wow by the way this is terrible and uh
like i do feel bad for horses too a
parent
break their spirit give them shoes then
they're one of you
she did not allow medicine or doctors
only prayers okay that'll get rid of
your cancer
also you had to give it all up you had
to give up everything you owned to join
okay
that's tough quote there's only one way
to join us that is to turn in all your
money and live with us
and people did so they've given up their
life savings where
are we putting all the money because
where is it where's the equity going
it's what's known as a what a what
a what
where are you burning it got hole a got
hole okay that we have in the back it's
it's a safe okay but it's in my uh
bedroom okay so your room has the god
hole where all the stuff in possession
yeah we just put all the money in there
well all the possessions get turned into
into money we
so they go in the god holds it and then
all the money goes in the god hole okay
which is the safe okay and that's just a
hole where that all goes to be done it's
over before god like god
it's not putting it near the devil
though
no it's all god it's how we show god
that we love him you're tipping god
basically give everything that we have
to my say the god safe
and he takes the money okay i just never
know he doesn't take it it stays there
oh and then you know if it needs to be
used
god tells me how to use it i need 30
please i'm going to bowl
that's yes exactly
uh so in 1909 so awkward could i have 25
to get some shrimp in heaven yes thank
so in 1909 white had taken a trip to
london and there lily mod allen went to
a revival and she heard white preaching
quote i knew it was the right thing for
me
now her father
forbade her from joining but she
hops on a ship
and heads for america
and uh he used his connections and told
uh immigration if he looks she's she's
17 and she has tuberculosis so they're
looking for her okay
and um
by 1910 pillar of fire had 20 000
members and obviously [ __ ] a lot of
money because if 20 thousand members are
giving up their life savings yes a lot
in the got hole so the police chief knew
they wouldn't get any results by just
demanding to see lily
he thought you know they'd have to get
someone in on the inside and he thought
well alice is perfect oh right
undercover she can blend in she loves
the idea she's like let's do this
and fortunately the cult was listed in
the city directory and it was hello all
right hello
yes we're the cult uh
just look under c's for cults hello um
yes we put all your money in the god
hole
that's right all your possessions
so it turns out the headquarters are in
south central and it's just a five
minute walk from alice's house so it's
all it's great i'm undercover it's close
to home
you don't want undercover close to your
home yeah you know what i mean she's
going to leave as her yeah
i don't know yet kids i don't these are
i found them i'm going to put them i
want to sell them and then give you the
money yes
she went she goes to the house on a
saturday and so the house is surrounded
by tons of of like hedges and plants
that you can't see in
um
the property once been a farm there's
still chicken coops around and a
windmill that had burned down right
after they bought the land sure it's a
fire mill so alice knocks on the door
and then it opens someone opens it and
she can hear women chanting sure great
sign i think i'm in the right spot yes
this is my my place
and she tells them she's looking for the
truth
and wanted to join
she wants to learn even more about the
pillar of fire by the way is there an
easier like the easiest undercover
they're like oh that's exactly in line
with what we're doing that's how we do
it get in here
so
she's brought in and she's taken into
this dark room
all the windows are covered by curtains
except there's one spot where a light
shines in onto a chair and they tell
alice to sit right there
that's your light chair there you go
so
soon the cult members who live there all
come and the whole room fills up
and they start singing hymns
all of which have been written by white
so she wrote all of her own these are
very good
these are really good uh who put the bop
in the bop shape up shape up come on
everyone who put the shem in the shama
ding dong let's go oh jesus christ
songs like soon i shall be blood washed
soon i shall be blood washed
and that'll be fun too
also the cry of the soul it's the cry of
the soul
you put it in god's hole
your money goes and fixes you it's
volume so
i'm going in and out
can i get twenty dollars from god's holy
oh yes god sorry
uh alice sang along
really it's one of those where you're
going like that
some throw the waters some throw the
flood some throw the fire but all
through the blood there's a lot of blood
stuff a lot of blood stuff a lot of
blood
it's fine
after singing they talk
so who are you and
she convinces them that she's ready to
join right
she uh then
i don't know what exactly how much she's
there like all day and night so she's at
one point walking around she's going
into different rooms looking for lily
allen she can't find her mm-hmm well
she's this is like a real condensed
donnie bros it really is it all happened
it really did yeah it all happens in one
day it's crazy yeah she was my best
friend
she was my best friend it's like it's
like a a tv movie or right you got to
come out we got to get through this
season all right come back come on she
gets hired let's go by the way there is
a japanese colombo
in in general they made a japanese
columbo and he walks around in the
colombo outfit with messed up hair is so
[ __ ] great okay when did they make it
i just saw like a little a little
snippet of it and i was like i have to
find this
and it's hugely popular like they
[ __ ] does he do the like and just one
more thing
uh so
the jumpers start to trust alice
sure i mean it's 4 30. it's 4 30. by the
end of the night i think it's like
midnight she talked one of them into
telling her where lily was okay wow this
person's like yeah she's not allowed to
tell anything
you've been here so long and we've
gotten so close
turns out lily was on their 81-acre
compound that was full of sad little
buildings in new jersey
and that's where lily was she was
washing dishes and scrubbing floors
the new york times quote they give the
impression of being places to discipline
people in
right it's very scientology-ish yeah i
mean it's exactly scientology i i worked
at a studio here in
um it used to be a a local news station
okay in uh silver lake
and uh while we were there we were doing
talking dead and
the scientologist bought it
so we had like we were finishing out the
season but there were dudes walking
around khakis and blue pants and you
would walk by and they would just be
down scrubbing a grate with a toothbrush
yeah right and you'd be like oh cool man
oh see yeah did you guys hear sponges
so alice after that night
she leaves and she tells the chief
she knows where lily is and they got
word to the new jersey police and lily's
father so she [ __ ] did it she was
busting this thing open in a day in a
day
the press now suddenly show her respect
the los angeles all cops should be women
that's right the los angeles herald
cheered for her finding a missing person
quote for whom
sluice of two continents had searched
papers all over the country celebrating
her work
the saint
uh
joseph news press interviewed her and
she said her beat was around the moving
picture shows cheap theaters dance halls
and places where certain classes of
young women are apt to spend their time
so in other words after doing undercover
work for this real weird church
everyone's like this is the person who
was undercover and they're like where
are you normally yeah what are you doing
where are you normally well tell us
about your policing now now we're
interested but also it's like revealing
to this cult like here she is and here's
who she is yeah it's really crazy
uh so she was in all those places to
make sure things were orderly and the
girls were behaving
and so this is a different that's a
tough well this is a different spin on
what we've been told right
quote the very young and the beginners i
make every effort to influence away from
the resorts
so i think by resort she means the
places
right she also said she went into the
dressing rooms of women at lesser
theaters and tried to gain their
confidence
then talk them into following a better
life
so she's
a morality cop right and and she's and
she is elevating
it a little bit now that she's got like
you know she's got somewhere that will
listen to her well this explains why all
of the pastors and women's places were
on board with her because this is about
policing
yeah morality right like you shouldn't
be doing that right that's what she's
doing right
right she's a christian cop she's a
christian cop
uh
so it really it really sounds like she
spent a lot of her time
keeping girls away from possibly getting
sex or getting touched but imagine being
like changing hey
hey sorry girl you know like what the
[ __ ] yeah we don't uh do you like god
sorry would you what do you want to do
outside how do you want to handle it
you're under arrest if you don't like
god quote young girls are swept down by
this maelstrom of inequity which is set
before them in a form of riotous
pleasure
yes so fun she's the fun police she's
literally she's the [ __ ] she's the
the first lady cop in la and she's the
fun police
damn it
uh
just let him get fingered jesus all
right dave that's not the slogan of the
show uh she said the work was dignified
and part of applied christianity and in
this spirit of larger motherhood it's so
open it's so open that's all she's do
that's why
they all were like yeah let's have her
they they weren't thinking anything
other than this right that's how this is
the message right
she's been undercover the whole time
she also made sure
no miners were admitted to picture shows
without being accompanied by a parent or
legal guardian
i mean [ __ ] you
i mean i saw
what was i guess the first one was
saturday night fever i got into alone
north dallas 40.
my dad would be like
anything i wanted to see my dad would be
like okay yeah then like halfway through
be like there's a lot of sex in here
man
but you remember that feeling when you
used to go to a movie with your like
your parents like i think i've maybe
mentioned on this when my mother rented
the crying game and neither one of us
knew what it was yeah there's like
scenes like i also watched carol with my
mother and there's just like you know
really like like pretty strong sex like
any sex scene you're like so um
did you did you say that you had you got
more evaporated milk okay yeah great
uh she also made sure any objectionable
pictures were cut out of the movies uh
so she's policing she's like the [ __ ]
word
she's getting [ __ ] removed
unfortunately uh lily's father um
had been lying
so lily it turns out was not 17 she was
and she did not have tuberculosis so
they couldn't remove her she likes pb
and j
they couldn't remove her from a cult
because she's an adult right
two years later she was seen in
washington dc as a pillar of faith
missionary where she supported white's
announcement of the second coming of
jesus oh so she was fully in yeah she
would yeah right
that november she's allowed to be yes
yeah so that november chief sebastian
requested additional police women
because it was going so well okay
probably the highest compliment he could
give alice the police commission
approved it and by the end of 1912 the
lapd had uh
now four women cops all together and are
they all is doing the same [ __ ] it's the
same enforcement yeah it's just
christian christianity uh run amok we
just can't have nice things no
like
the best thing is to go have a little
[ __ ] sex when you're that eight like
let the kids go out and explore their
[ __ ] bodies we've been trying to in
this country i mean we've been trying to
stop people just pursuing like human
pleasure oh that's all we do that's all
we do yeah yeah
uh
so
sebastian also
told other departments across the
country to hire women so now this
spreads quote the natural protection
instinct of women makes her
advent in the field but natural so
they're literally yeah it leads to cops
all over the count female cops all over
the country to do this perhaps they're
christian cops
uh in 1913 sebastian went to d.c to the
chief of police convention and made a
strong case for them to hire women he
said crime was down and police women
made more arrests than policemen
alice also hit the road for seven months
starting in september 1912 she gave 136
lectures in support of hiring
policewomen
the reaction of the press and local
leaders was mostly positive
and the only reason that happens is
because it's
a christian thing right if it's just her
being a cop then no no no your brain
can't handle it
that's good
pretty soon the replacement in seattle
baltimore fargo north forks rochester
and 20 other cities
and in l.a they even raised the women's
pay to be equal to men's wow i mean
it's hard to root right now it really is
i mean cheer it really is for australian
fans well i didn't want to do this story
for so long because i was like it's
about a cop
after lobbying by alice the lapd created
a policy that women could only be
questioned by female police officers
okay well that's good yeah
that's a good thing right there yeah i'm
still but then what is she doing with it
right yeah on the other side right
uh within a few more years los angeles
made pay for policemen and policewomen
uniforms sending alice home every month
with the same 120 as her male peers
alice started wearing a police uniform
her and the chief designed it it was
khaki like the rest of the department in
the summer
summer clothes for cops sure khakis lapd
was written on her collar and a military
trim coat with a long pleated skirt wow
alice became the department's official
historian in 1934 and set up a la cop
museum in highland park which i've been
to oh really yeah i i think it's
history well we filmed we filmed
something for marin there
but they have like the from the
hollywood shootout they have like the
car wow
um she was with the lapd until she
retired in 1940
alice wells died in 1957 her funeral had
a
a 10 woman honor guard and then white
yeah that's still going the pillars of
seriously is
still around
and she wrote the hymns
it's how can you i don't know i never
understood about scientology it's like
it i mean you give religion some
distance and time okay maybe you can
like yeah it was a long time ago things
were different back then men were
parting seas back then
but like there's nothing like a religion
conceived in the 40s you're like emmy
it's so weird you're sure we live in
space really it's um
there uh yeah they're still around and
um they've distanced themselves from her
at the beginning a little bit sure now
but they're
you know there they are doing their
thing good well i'm glad they're still
that that's you know you're kind of
looking for like the the good like the
nice moral ending of this and there it
is
they're still around kicking it yeah
they're called pillar of fire
international it's a methodist christian
denomination
um they saw their headquarters in that
place in jersey so
yeah um and then did this sort of just
kind of eventually
just morph into allowing women to be
police officers i mean basically yeah
and you know i you could make the
argument that the only way they could
get on the force was by being christians
and doing that [ __ ] yeah yeah for sure
um
but yeah it's just all
yeah i mean you know it's like
it's it is
i mean to some extent it like speaks to
the problem we find today which is that
you know if you just send cops to every
situation it seems like they escalate
you know
so so this is sort of speaking to like
no let's you know how do you find a
diffuser um but again it's the american
version of the diffuser so of course
it's just like and the diffuser will
fill their head with christianity thank
you like you know [ __ ] yeah
that's why we can't have nice things
that's why we can't have nice things oh
she uh she actually uh white
uh
she like started
after this
she started you know getting involved
with the clue close clan and she like
like she was she's white yeah she went
terrible she could be in one episode
sure sure sure
it's so funny whenever i get in that car
cause i started doing this and
everyone's a villain i was like this is
exactly what happens now i was i was
doing this episode i'm recently and then
i get to this part
with the colt then i'm like god damn it
it's going to go into child molestation
because that's what they always do but
then a woman was running and i was like
oh great no child molestation literally
every cult run by a dude is about
molesting kids but if there's a woman
running it it's an interesting story oh
my god
that's
amazing
uh i mean yeah it does seem like most
cults are there to sexually satisfy the
person who talks to god in some way yes
nobody [ __ ] but me god just told me and
this one was just about power for her
right so finally a refreshing yay
um
uh sources uh a cool site that i found
truly
adventure.us they do
they just do stories like this yeah um
britannica
encyclopedia britannica yeah girl
and uh
america comes alive and then a bunch of
papers the
times on a little advertiser and buffalo
evening news etc
yeah that's it that's alice wells first
cop first lady cop in la here we go we
did it finally and finally everybody
everybody is a hero yep all winners
that's right
inside cars
you